well we just started 2024 and with this
video I have to update the list of
countries where my channel is officially
banned do you remember that Robo dog
that back in 2020 was making sure people
in Singapore followed social distancing
while its use was promoted by this man
with this creepy smile leean law the
prime minister of Singapore since 2004
Lee is part of the people's action party
which has continuously governed the
Asian City State since
1959 after all Singapore wouldn't be
what it is to today without Le's father
Lee kuu the first historic head of
government considered the founder of the
nation streets schools and public
buildings are all named after him and
when he died in 2015 he was given a
state funeral that would make the Kim
Dynasty and Queen Elizabeth look pale in
comparison well I think liwanu was a
great man I had the great Fortune of
becoming a personal friend and we saw
each other many many times add to the
fact that the Le are two of only three
men to have ever served as Prime
Ministers of Singapore and that the
people's action party has been winning
every election for 60 years with more
than 60% of the votes on paper Singapore
is a democracy however this democracy is
often described as authoritarian
illiberal bureaucratic or in some cases
a self- dictatorship whoever governs
Singapore must have that iron in him or
give it up this is not a game of cards
this is your life and mine I spent a
whole life time building this and as
long as I'm in charge nobody's going to
knock it down n he must have me spoken
otherwise it wouldn't explain why a
whole fleets of influencers visit
Singapore and describe it as a paradise
on earth a utopian Tech Island where
about 6 million people live in peace
wealth and Total Security and I could
tell you more they seem to be right
Singapore enjoys one of of the lowest
crime rates in the world perceived
corruption is virtually non-existent
unemployment is stable at 2% and 90% of
the residents own at least one home
moreover this m Asian state has one of
the best Health Care Systems on the
planet combined with a public education
system that puts the Western one to
shame as well as an average life
expectancy that exceeds 84 years
Singapore has four natureal reserves
Cutting Edge transport green
technologies and Facilities an efficient
waste man management system and
impressive tourist attractions maybe the
data will give you an even clearer idea
of how Singapore is doing with a GDP per
capita of
$887,000 singaporeans are better off
than qataris Canadians and icelanders
their average salary is close to $6,000
a month if we look at GDP just under
$500 billion we'd find that this dot on
the Asian Maps is a richer and more
productive country the demographic
giants like Egypt Nigeria and Pakistan a
Nations considered wealthy such as
Finland New Zealand and Luxembourg so
where do you apply to move there on the
website of the Singapore Ministry of
Manpower or by taking part in the global
investor program you just need to invest
$2.5 million in the country's
development no wonder Singapore is owned
to 240,000 millionaires making up almost
50% of the population and 46
billionaires among them the richest is
Eduardo Saverin one of the co-founders
of Facebook who recently obtained
Singaporean citizenship desp being
Brazilian the power of money to apply
for citizenship you need to live in
Singapore for at least 2 years and
demonstrate excellent entrepreneurial
skills and or family ties with another
Singaporean the downside is that dual
citizenship is not allowed so you'll
have to give up your other passport not
a big deal given that currently the
Singaporean passport is the strongest in
the world if you have it you can visit
193 countries without any Visa watch out
however in Singapore not everyone is
treated equally forign migrant workers
especially in the fields of
manufacturing and domestic cleaning are
often underpaid or not paid at all
deprived of the passports abused forced
to work without holidays or sick leave
and housed in crowded dormitories This
Modern form of slavery reportedly
affects at least 9,000 people and is
carried out by actual agency that
recruits staff mainly from Indonesia the
Philippines and Myanmar to contribute to
Singapore's development you're not part
of this category you have the privilege
to not worry great suppose you managed
to get a document where where would you
go and live can I suggest the urban
division of marine parade a cheerful
residential area that didn't even exist
until the 70s because in recent decades
Singapore has extended its original
Surface by 25% simply by reclaiming
swamps building along the coasts and
throwing rocks and Sands into the sea to
create new pieces of land from nothing
for example the iconic Marina Bay Sands
one of the world's largest casino
resorts the island of Jong an important
petrochemical Hub and Singapore's jungle
airport where built on so-call lands
reclaimed by the government to lead a
peaceful life in Singapore you have to
follow some basic rules that frankly
don't sound too bad you can't smoke in
public except in designated areas you
know that terrible stench that plugs
some train stations well in Singapore
say goodbye to that you can't spit on
the
streets and I spit in the face of people
who don't want to be cool nor litter if
I think about it I'd readily punish
those who keep on loitering really you
can't bother a person by singing or
playing a musical instrument leave your
mandoline at home you can't feed pigeons
you can't leave a public bathroom dirty
nor cross outside of pedestrian
Crossings it's about common sense think
that in a certain European country
starting with an eye and ending with a
why are getting rare to find but I don't
think I made it clear enough these
aren't just guide rules to follow but
actual laws punishable by fines or even
imprisonment Singapore is known as the
city of fines for a reason throw track
trash on the street that's $1,000 fine
do it again $2,000 and I'll send you to
pick up trash in a public park I find
this loss very stupid you're actually
humilating your own citizens and if you
are doing that I don't think I should be
a citizen of this country speed on the
street the first time $1,000 is fine do
it multiple times and it's from $5,000
upwards cross the street outside of
pedestrian Crossings give me $500 and
you also get three months in prison for
again $2,000 And1 in may result in
accidents that lead to Serious injury or
even fatality if you travel on any
public transport stay in hotels or walk
in certain areas eating durian is
prohibited durian is a spiny fruit
typical of Southeast Asia that once
opened emits a noting stench that makes
own Margarita's armpits after cycling
sessions smell like desert roses today
this is a modern city it was more like
the durian you try and squeeze it your
hand gets hurt and so so they say right
throw out the Doran but inside the Doran
you know some very useful ingredients
high protein and we will progress
moreover since 1992 in Singapore it's
impossible to find buy produce or even
import chewing gum deemed guilty of
dirting bus and Metro seats floors and
even streets in this case penalties can
SAR up to
$100,000 and include two years in prison
you know all those black dots that plug
the streets of our cities they are
flattened and Blacken chewing gums
imagine famous words by John Lon imagine
a clean city where the guy who spits gum
on the street is punished this
Singaporean dystopia is kind of growing
on me believe it or not cleanliness and
Order are pillars of Singapore's
national identity to understand why just
take a quick step back in time the city
of fins boasts a millennial long history
inextricably linked to that of Malaysia
however the story of modern day
Singapore begins in 1819 when the
British East India Company seeking a
port near the street of Mal a trade
route then controlled by the Dutch
identified an island that suited their
needs having signed a treaty with the
sultanate of Johor a political entity
located in south of the Malay Peninsula
the British obtained the island as a
concession and retained its original
name Singapura the lion City and there's
no doubt the British knew how to make
lemonade out of lemons immediately the
port of Singapore was made tax-free
meaning devoid of Duties and tolls as a
result Chinese Malay and Indian
Merchants as well as European
businessmen found it convenient to pass
through trade and even leave there once
incorporated as a colony of the crown in
1867 parallel to the opening of the suet
Canal Singapore served as a crucial hub
for exporting Rubber and Tin then taken
from Mal Asia to Europe on the other
hand however the lion city was invaded
by criminal associations slave Traders
while the local population which reached
200,000 at the turn of the 900s lived in
terrible conditions and it didn't get
any better in 1942 the Japanese empire
occupied Singapore 3 years of Terror and
repression followed the local Society
had already disintegrated torn apart by
violence and opium food and drinking
water were scars and most families lived
in so-called Kongs slums and stilled
houses divided by rigid ethnic religious
boundaries in this seemingly unsolvable
chaos of issues the singaporeans
entrusted the country to a charismatic
leader in 1954 Lewan Yu a lawyer of
Chinese Origins educated in London
founded the People's action party which
in 1959 won the country's first
Democratic elections by a landslide
after all three quarters of the
Singaporean population had and still
have Chinese Origins nonetheless as
prime minister Lee promoted equality for
all citizens from the start so much so
that even today Singapore recognizes
four official languages Mandarin Chinese
English Malay and Tamil Indian each
representative of the country's major
communities in 1960 lequan used party at
established the Housing and Development
board aimed at constructing buildings
this was to ensure order and acceptable
living conditions for the now million
Singaporean citizens in just 5 years a
staggering 400,000 people moved into
government funded Apartments the same
reclaimed lands we just talked about
were used over time to build new
neighborhoods and housing blocks this
was a mut flat swamp even today the real
estate market in Singapore is protected
80% of the population lives in state
buildings and buying them is made
possible because all citizens under 55
must contribute 20% of their salary to
funds from these funds they can withdraw
money solely for buying a house or
rather acquiring the right to live there
however urban planning had to be
accompained by the Carol public affairs
in 1968 Leen used people's Action Party
launched the campaign keep Singapore
clean this initiative was aimed at
encouraging singaporeans to absolutely
use trash bins and discouraging
littering through f at the time Lee
stated no other Hallmark of our success
will be more evident than becoming the
greenest and cleanest city in all of
South Asia since then keep Singapore
clean has been periodically updated with
posters and advertisements to
continually remind the population of
these measures over time these media
campaigns have also been used to
influence the will of citizens cesy is
our way of life let's save precious
water I can speak Mandarin Mandarin's in
dialects out girl or boy two is enough
the second can wait I'm accused often of
interfering in private lives of
citizens yes we wouldn't be here we
would not have made the economic
progress if we had not intervened on
very personal matters who your neighbor
is how you live the noise you make how
you spit or where you spit we have an
example of a poster like this from the
police of Singapore it says if you
molest we will arrest sounds in the norm
right there's a catch in Singapore Being
Ned in our own home is also considered a
form of
harrassment Let Me Explain If you
unfortunately expose yourself to the
public while in your underwear say
through your bathroom window you could
be charged with public indecency and
it's possible that a police officer
could burst into your home and slap you
with a hefty $2,000 fine but wait a
minute up to 3 years in jail a fine and
orcanon I need to explain this too in
Singapore as well as in Malaysia brune
canning with a ratan cane a type of
tropical Palm was introduced as a
punishment during the British colonial
period today it's prescribed for about
30 different charges harassment
obviously kidnapping theft abuse
exertion drug trafficking and other
serious crimes that can also carry the
death penalty but let's get back to
canning because things really get
interesting here according to a 2019
survey nearly half of all Singaporean
parents use small sticks to punish
disrespectful disob I or lying children
as stated by the Ministry of Education
the same is done in schools but only in
cases when absolutely necessary what
that means only they know in Singapore
one can easily be C for vandalism this
happened to Jolan Wham an activist who
in 2017 hung flyers on a train and along
with colleagues traveled with a book and
a blindfold over their eyes in 2021 wh
was finded $1,000 for vandalism eight
Strokes of a ranc Kane and
$4,500 for unor Ed public assembly
penalties converted to 22 days in prison
under the public order Act of 2009 you
can't organize a demonstration or
gathering of any kind without first
getting permission from the authorities
but let's take another look at the
formidable train protest the flyers in
the book they were holding referred to
operation Spectrum a mass arrest of 22
people carried out without trial by the
Singaporean government in 1987 to thwart
an alleged Marxist conspiracy at the
time activists were accused of
attempting to over throw the Singaporean
State system through a coup however it
is widely believed that Lee and his
peers used an excuse to silence
inconvenient opponents it's not
surprising the Singapore government has
been suppressing dissident for decades
when lean 's party came to power in 59
they promised that Singapore would soon
achieve Federal unification with
Malaysia Singapore lacking significant
natural resources and being small in
size was on the brink of collapse even
the British who still had formal control
over the island were pushing for the
Union some socialist members of The
People's action party however feared
that once unification was complete
Malaysia would help Lee eliminate any
oppositions to his power and you
certainly can't maintain order if you
have opponents so in February 1963 Lee
launched operation coldstore and mass
arrest with dubious intentions aimed at
paralyzing the Communist organization
over 100 people suspected of plotting an
armed coup were detained with the
Socialist front crippled the pap won an
absolute majority in Parliament in
September gained total independence from
the United Kingdom and completed
unification with Malaysia do you want to
know the irony due to political and
racial tensions between the Chinese
majority in Singapore and the Malaysian
political class and fears that
Singapore's sport would become more
important than karur in 1967 the
Malaysian Parliament voted to expel
Singapore from the Federation left alone
by both its neighbors and the British
the city state of Singapore was
practically forced to itself an
autonomous Republic you see the whole of
my adult
life
I I had believed in Malaysia mder now
imagine being head of a small country
lacking resources what next well you get
creative first locking an Army in 65 Lee
requested technical support from some
Israeli military officers T Aviv in fact
materially helped Singapore build its
Armed Forces secondly Lee facilitated
the creation of a series of State
companies that would would produce oil
and steel build and repair ships import
food and Timber and in recent decades
move into Financial Services sustainable
Technologies and biomedical engineering
finally he encouraged foreign
investments through favorable tax
policies and the always convenient Port
of Singapore which is currently the
busiest in the world today both China
and the United States invest in
Singapore making the city states the
most important geopolitical pieace in
asan the association of Southeast Asian
Nations and that's why Singapore is the
Main Financial Hub of Asia and the third
globally after New York and London let's
give Lee his due the nation's father
understood 60 years ago that instead of
isolating and turning Singapore into his
personal playground like our old friend
from Turkmenistan do you remember him
well he understood that it would be
better to broaden Horizons and diversify
the country's economy as much as
possible lianu doesn't seem to have been
just a prime minister the same goes for
his colleagues his son lisian long and
go Chong who served from 1990 to 2004
rather the head of the government is the
CEO of a company Singapore whose board
of directors is formed by the papap a
CEO after all aims to maximize profit
operate in global markets but also keep
work environments clean and orderly and
strive to ensure the well-being of all
his employees in this case the citizens
it doesn't end there the media sector in
Singapore is practically a duopoly
consisting of the state-owned media Corp
and SP media media whose board members
are members or ex politicians of the
papap unsurprisingly no news can be made
public without the express approval of
the ministry of information moreover
since 2019 The Government Can censor
online content deemed false or
manipulated needless to say if the
opposition were to contest censorship
they would be accused of spreading fake
news at this point we might wonder what
do singaporeans think according to a
survey by the PE Research Center and
American Think Tank 80% % of
singaporeans are satisfied with how
their democracy actually functions after
all the more positive the results
achieved by the company Singapore the
less inclined its citizens will be to
protest nothing wrong with that this
Paradigm fits well with Singaporean
culture centered on the concept of kiasu
a term that roughly means fear of losing
losing not just a competition but also
an opportunity there is the chance to
work hard together to reach Greater
Heights on the other hand the population
fears climate change which could sub
merge the city's coasts and the recent
rise in the coast of living and real
estate considering also that Singapore
Imports 90% of its food from abroad
mainly from Malaysia meanwhile without
noise of brutality Singapore continues
undisturbed to limit descent and put a
good face on a bad game because after
all liwan Yu and his successors have
literally legitimized a dystopia let's
ask ourselves how are we doing in our
own Society our own Western Society if
we come to admire a country like this
now if you'll excuse me I have to go get
my dose of
cannings